true story because of the pandemic more
people are staying home
that makes sense right and guess what
they're doing they're staying home
and according to studies they're eating
cereal for breakfast
this is all true a lot of people eating
cereal
and as a result there's a nationwide
shortage
of grape nuts cereal it's kind of
surprising
what did you just say i said it's kind
of surprising that all these people oh
not that part goddamn it what did you
say about grape nuts
oh well it's this true story it actually
made the new york times check it out
the company that makes grape nuts said
there's a product shortage because
they've actually had a pro yeah of
course there is i mean i should have
seen this coming
oh you really screwed the pooch this
time andy stupid stupid stupid
it's fine andy it's just cereal just a
cereal
i defy you to find anything as loud and
as painful to eat
with less flavor than grape nuts there's
no other breakfast food in the world
that makes me wonder if i'm swallowing
my own teeth and
go on name me another cereal that you
can use to start a terrarium
all right sure andy you're right grape
nuts does all those things but
what are you doing now andy i'm trying
to score a few boxes on the dark web
damn it oh it's too late there's nothing
left with heroin
add to cart oh oh come on andy you're
overreacting to this whole thing look
it's not just me
it's the 50 000 users who follow my
daily instagram feed
great nut sunsets see that's in fiji
and that is kilimanjaro in the
background wow
that's beautiful andy but don't you
think it's time to move on
well it's easy for you to say you've
never loved anything the way i've loved
great nuts
i have two children well i hope you hug
them tonight
because i just learned your life can
change in an instant
one minute you're sitting pretty with a
belly full of undigestible grape nuts
and then bam darkness oh
i hate you god hey andy
good news according to this article the
grape nut shortage is only till march
you'll have your grape nuts back next
month
yeah thanks a lot conan but i'm not
waiting around to get my heart broken
again
i'm making my own grape nut cereal out
of peanut shells and coffee grounds
okay well i
oh my god that hurts hurts bad
oh andy and this magazine's
fake we made it for the skit hey we got
a great show
colin quinn's gonna be joining us we'll
take a break we'll be right back
richter you're cuckoo
did that used to it